نظرًا لأن لدينا الآن أشخاصًا
تعافوا من فيروس كورونا ، فهل من
الممكن تطوير نوع من
العلاج باستخدام الأجسام المضادة التي
طوروها كاستجابة للمرض
في واقع الأمر ، وهذا بالضبط ما
نقوم به نحن نستعد
لدراسة كل من مصل النقاهة وهي
كلمة مهمة لقول أخذ المصل من
شخص تعافى تمامًا ، احصل
عليه بطريقة يمكنك من خلالها
تقوية بروتينات غاما
غلوبولين والأجسام المضادة من هذا المصل
واستخدامها كطريقة لكليهما
العلاج وربما العلاج الوقائي ولكن
العلاج في الغالب سؤال جيد جدًا ، إنه أحد
أولوياتنا القصوى هنا في
المطعم الذي إما مصاب
بالفيروس أو ليس على علم بأن
الفيروس يتلامس مع الطعام
أو العبوة ، فهل من الممكن بعد ذلك أن  يمكنني
أن أصاب بالفيروس من خلال هذا الطعام
أو العبوة ماذا عن ذلك ، لذا فهو
مثير للاهتمام ، لذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء
لن تعرف أنك تحصل عليه من
الطعام الذي تتناوله.  ليس أحد
تلك الأنواع من الفيروسات ، إنه
فيروس تنفسي ، أعتقد
أن اللحظة الأكثر خطورة في توصيل الطعام
إليك هي في الواقع التفاعل وجهًا لوجه
إذا كان لديك واحد مع
الشخص الذي يقوم بتوصيل الطلبات ، لذلك من الأفضل أن تكون
قادرًا  لدفعها لهم عبر الإنترنت
أو أي نظام أساسي تستخدمه
لطلب الطعام ثم اجعلهم
يتركونه خارج باب منزلك وانتظر حتى
يغادروا ثم الحصول على
الطعام ، ننصحك بالابتعاد عن
المتنزهات والشواطئ المحلية والوطنية
في هذا الوقت أيضًا ، أريد
أن أظل قادرًا على الاستمتاع بالهواء الطلق ، لكن
أفعل ذلك بمسؤولية بعد
التباعد الاجتماعي عن شخص آخر ، هل نسمع
هذا كثيرًا سانجاي ، انظر ، أعني أنه لا يوجد
سبب يمنعك من الخروج ،
هذا واحد من هؤلاء  الأشياء التي كنت
تعتقد أنك تحدثت فيها عن التباعد الاجتماعي أو
الجسدي كما أحب أن أسميها ،
عليك فقط الحفاظ على ذلك
عندما تكون بالخارج أيضًا وإذا كنت
تعرف ما إذا كنت تمارس الرياضة إذا كنت
تركب دراجة  أو في وقت ما  على هذا النحو ،
تأكد من أنك تمسح الأسطح
وما زلت تمارس النظافة الجيدة
على الرغم من الرجاء الحفاظ على هدوئك ،
لا يسع بعض الناس إلا الذعر أو القلق في
وقت الأزمات ،
حيث سافر العديد من مراسلي CNN إلى مناطق حرب
قاموا بتغطية وحشية لا يمكن تصورها
و  اليأس ، شهد نيك باتون والش
صراعات في أماكن مثل سوريا ،
العراق ، فنزويلا ، إيران ، أفغانستان ، انضم
إلينا ويعيش الآن من لندن ليعطينا
القليل من المنظور في
وسط هذه القصة الكبيرة جدًا ، تعلم أن نيكي
لديك قطعة جديدة على cnn.com  ما هي
بعض الدروس التي يمكنك مشاركتها من
تجاربك بشكل جيد على الفور
عمليًا فقط لا تقلق كثيرًا بشأن
الطعام وجميع الأشخاص يشترون الذعر ولكن
أحد الأشياء التي تعلمتها أنا والعديد من
زملائنا من الأزمات
والصراعات حول العالم  هو أن
الناس لديهم قدرة غير عادية على
إطعام أنفسهم في أوقات الأزمات في كثير من الأحيان
عندما يتعرضون للقصف أو على خط المواجهة
أو تتحول المنازل إلى أنقاض.
مجرد مرض ، إنه مرض مروع
يغير حياتنا اليومية ولكن لا تقلق
كثيرًا بشأن الطعام ولا تتصرف
بطريقة تحرم
كبار السن أو الضعفاء من الطعام عن طريق
الشراء الذعر وإفراغ المتاجر.
إن رؤيتك في جميع أنحاء العالم هو نوع من
الجنون 1.2 على ذلك أيضًا يمكنك
العيش بدون ورق التواليت ، لقد فعلنا ذلك جميعًا
في وظائفنا حول العالم إذا كان
عليك القيام بعملك في
وسط مجال نعم إنه مفيد جدًا  ولكن
من الممكن تمامًا أن توجد
بدش فقط وقطعة من الصابون ، لذلك لا
تقلق كثيرًا بشأن أن
بعض الأشياء التي تجعلها
تميز جيدًا حقًا في Nick بين الأشياء
التي يمكنك التحكم فيها والأشياء التي لا يمكنك التحكم فيها
السيطرة ،
حسنًا ، تفصيل ، نعم ، أعني أن أحد
الأشياء التي يجب أن نتعلمها في عملنا في
المواقف المعقدة مثل النزاعات هو
أن هذه الأشياء التي يمكنك القلق بشأنها
والتي يمكن أن يكون لها تأثير عليها
وهناك أشياء مثل ما
سيحدث في مايو ما الذي يحدث  ليحدث
في o  هناك قرية لا يمكنك أن ترى
المستقبل البعيد الذي لا يمكنك تغييره ببساطة ،
لذا لا تضيع طاقتك في
القلق بشأن تلك الأشياء
التي لا يمكنك التحكم فيها على الإطلاق ، تقلق
بشأن الأشياء التي
يمكنك تغييرها  ساعد اليوم ماذا
ستأكل اليوم ماذا ستفعل
لاحقًا اليوم ماذا
ستفعل غدًا حاول أن تقصر الأشياء
التي يتراكم عليها قلقك وأيضًا
إلى شيء مهم للغاية يجب
أن يتذكره الناس أن يكون لطيفًا مع الناس من
حولك  هذا ليس لأننا جميعًا
نريد أن نعيش في مجتمع سعيد متشابك
الأيدي ، إنه حقًا مفيد لك
أن
الناس من حولك يحبونك ويريدون
مساعدتك لأنهم سيخبرونك
بالأشياء الضرورية التي قد تكون
مترددة في إخبارك بأنك
بحاجة حقًا إلى معرفة جيرانك المرضى أو في
حالتي في بعض الأحيان
سنقصف الجانب الآخر من هذا التل ، لذا لا
تذهب إلى هناك فهذه مسألة مهمة
لا تتعلق بالإيثار ولكن لرعاية
نفسك
هذا ما  عادة ما تبدو مدن إينيس
مثل هذا الوقت من العام الضباب الدخاني الكثيف الذي
يغطي الأفق ولكن هذا العام
هناك شيء مختلف في
السماء الزرقاء في العديد من المدن الصينية
حيث تحسن تلوث الهواء خاصة
ووهان المركز الأصلي
لفيروس كورونا القاتل الذي استخدمه العديد
من الصينيين.  ارتداء لتصفية
الهواء الملوث الذي يتم ارتداؤه الآن للحماية
من الفيروس ،
أصدرت وكالة ناسا ووكالة الفضاء الأوروبية صورًا للأقمار الصناعية من
يناير تظهر مستويات ثاني أكسيد النيتروجين وو هانز
والانخفاض الكبير في فبراير
بعد 11 مليون شخص تم
عزل انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون فيها خلال
الأسابيع الأربعة الماضية  بنسبة 25 في المائة على الأقل
بالنسبة لأكبر ملوث في العالم
مما قد يعني انخفاضًا بمقدار 200 مليون
طن من ثاني أكسيد الكربون ، وهذا أكثر
دراماتيكية من أي شيء آخر
رأيته من حيث التأثير على الانبعاثات
ولكنها بالطبع تؤثر عليه
كانت حياة الناس والاقتصاد
دراماتيكية بنفس القدر ، يقول مركز
أبحاث الطاقة والهواء النظيف إن الفحم
يخدع  شهد المجموع في محطات الطاقة المشتعلة
انخفاضًا بنسبة 36 في المائة مقارنة بالعام الماضي ،
أظهر بحثهم أيضًا انخفاض
انبعاثات الكربون من صناعة الطيران
بسبب
انخفاض الطلب وتحسنت أيضًا قيود السفر على نطاق واسع في هونغ كونغ المجاورة ،
حيث تسبب الفيروس في
إغلاق جزئي هناك.  الكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يعملون من المنزل مما
قلل من حجم حركة المرور وقلل
من الازدحام المروري يحذر نشطاء مثل
باتريك فونج
من التأثير طويل المدى لتلوث الهواء
في مدينته الأم ، حيث أصدرت شبكة الهواء النظيف
هذا التحذير المثير للصحة العامة
هناك 1500 حالة وفاة مبكرة في
عام واحد فقط في هونغ كونغ
تكلفتها تكلفة تلوث الهواء ، يقدر أحد الباحثين
في جامعة ستانفورد أن
التحسن المفاجئ في جودة الهواء فوق
الصين قد ينقذ بالفعل عشرات
الآلاف من الأشخاص من
الوفيات المبكرة بسبب
تلوث الهواء ولكن حتى نشطاء البيئة.
حذر من أنه من السابق لأوانه
الاحتفال
في فترة قصيرة  جمهورية الصين الشعبية قد يكون الهواء فوق الصين
أنظف ولكن لا أحد يعرف
مدى عواقب هذا الوباء القاتل
على المجتمع إيفان واتسون سي إن إن
هونغ كونغ